next year I'm gonna go and fight again  because actually I want to fight once on  the same car with Bella oh damn that's  my last fight she can headline the card  I can open it you know what I mean type  thing but you know that's just sick how  many times is that gonna happen in  history never yeah yeah so I mean I mean  I mean barring you know what I mean like  lightning striking you know a car  accident some [ __ ] you know Bella's  UFC champ whoever Champion whatever  League she wants to join yeah I agree  there's no I would take that she's as  much I mean it's like me when I look at  Beau nickel I'm like what do you think  is having that guy I'm like he's a champ  dude like lose weight or get a bigger  weight class